next witness is mr. Danny Glover actor
producer and an activist for various
causes he's currently goodwill
ambassador for UNICEF chairman of the
board of trans Africa forum and an
African American lobbying organization
for Africa and the Caribbean and a
friend of Harry Belafonte
you'll recognize for five minutes Thank
You mr. Coates it's not often that you
hear the words of a young man and they
enliven your emotional memory your
historic memory as he just did at this
moment thank you so much I am deeply
honored to be here today
offering my testimony of this historic
meeting about the reckoning of a crime
against humanity that is foundational to
the development democracy and material
well-being in this country a national
reparations policy is moral democratic
and economic imperative I sit here as
the great-great grandson of a former
slave Mary Brown who was freed by the
Emancipation Proclamation on January 1st
1863 I had the fortune of meeting her as
a small child I also sit here as the
grandson we seem a hung Lynn Rufus Mac
Huntley
maternal grandparents born before Plessy
vs. Ferguson Supreme Court decision in
1896 and for significant portion of
their lives they worked as sharecroppers
and tenant farmers in rural Georgia
until they were able to save enough
money to purchase a small farm it was a
fist and farmers the site despite much
progress over the centuries this hearing
is yet another important step in the
long and heroic struggle of
african-americans secure reparations for
the damage is inflicted by enslavement
and post emancipation and ratio
exclusionary policies many of the
organization's who are present today at
this hearing are amongst the historical
contributors to the present national
discourse congressional deliberations
and Democratic Party presidential
campaign policy discussions about
reparations we also indebted to the work
of Congress men John Conyers for
shepherding this legislation the
adoption of HR 40 can be a signature
legislative achievement especially
within the context of the United Nations
International decade of people of
African descent we should also note that
the Common Market Nations and the
Caribbean community CARICOM reparations
Commission chaired by Professor Sir
Hillary Beckles
who is here with us today has exercised
a leadership role from which we as a
nation can benefit our sustained direct
effective policy actions in full
collaboration with African Americans and
progressive citizens allies is the
ultimate proof
the sincerity of our national commitment
to repair the damages of the legally and
often religiously sanctioned inhumanity
of slavery segregation and current
structural racism that limit full put
democratic participation and material
advancement of african-americans and of
our country's progress as a beacon of
justice and equality so I call on all of
the elected public officials into
Congress to demonstrate your commitment
in action today and stand forth with
congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee and
cosine cosine HR 40 in closing with the
insightful and still I'm I close excuse
me with the insightful and still
relevant words of dr. Martin Luther King
jr. in 1968 and I quote why is the issue
of equality still so far from solution
in America a nation which professes
itself to be democratic inventive
hospitable to new ideas rich productive
and awesomely powerful justice for black
people were not flow into society merely
from Court decisions nor from mountains
of political oratory nor will a few
token changes quelled all the temtempo
us yearnings of millions of
disadvantaged black people white America
must recognize that justice for black
people cannot be achieved without
radical changes in the structure of our
society the comfortable the entrenched
the privileged cannot continue to
tremble at the prospect of change in the
status quo
thank you thank you
[Applause]